I get on email and talk to people well
it's really exciting to bring lots of
lots of people together all over the
world to create knowledge share it
freely with everybody there's a real
sense and all of my projects that we're
doing something important and that you
see that inspiration and a lot of the
people who I work with and so that
brings a lot of fun a lot of joy to the
work I don't spend much I just have a
lot of fun when you know obviously there
there's a lot of work to do and dealing
with lots and lots of things going on
all the time is a constant struggle but
you know in general it's it's all fun so
I don't really perceive it as work even
so the main catalyst for the origin of
the IDF or Wikipedia came from watching
the growth of the free software movement
open source software most people know it
so altogether you know all over the web
people were coming together programmers
and building the new linux and apache
PHP perl mysql all the software is
really the software that runs the
internet and it's all freely licensed
and it's all written for the most part
by volunteers all over the world and
seeing that new mode of production
caused me to think that she you know
this this shouldn't stop with just
programming that we can build all kinds
of other things so the encyclopedia was
the first project and now the rest of
the library and search engine and
everything else trying to really push
that whole idea forward
so the wikimedia foundation of course is
the nonprofit organization that I
founded runs wikipedia and lectionary
and all of the other nonprofit sites I
think the main my main focus for where I
think we'll go in the future is focused
on the languages of the developing world
so right now we're really really strong
and in all the languages of Europe we're
strong in Japanese Chinese but we're not
so strong in the languages of Africa the
languages of India but those are all
coming and that's really an increasing
focus of my interest in my work is to
try to see what I can do to help promote
and get things going and get get some
excitement going in that part of the
world I think one of the things that is
we know one of the impacts here is that
we have a much higher degree of informal
learning than we used to have that's not
to say that that formal learning is
declining is just say that after people
have finished their formal education we
have such a greater opportunity for
informal education 35 years ago you
might you know read a newspaper story
about I don't know albania and you might
think albania barely barely know
anything about it and i don't know the
history I should go to the library and
look that up but I mean frankly nobody
ever much went to the library to look
things up it was you know that's quite a
journey you have to put aside a lot of
your energy to go and do something like
that whereas now when somebody wonders
about Albania they just type Albania
into a search engine they get typically
the Wikipedia article they get a nice
basic history and background and they
can really dig very deep if they want to
follow the sources and you can learn a
lot all that kind of learning I think
helps people to become you know better
citizens better decision makers in their
own lives sometimes its political but
sometimes it's personal decisions that
people won't make that they can make
with a lot more knowledge than they
in the past simply because it's so easy
to informally get the basic information
that you need obviously that's not to
say that that the state of information
on the internet is perfect it certainly
isn't there's a lot of problems of you
know reliability accuracy I think people
have a lot to learn in terms of figuring
out what does make a good source and how
do you know when something is is
reliable or not but overall you know
this this instant access to information
is is almost you know completely a good
thing I don't think there's ever you
know any case outside of science fiction
examples where you can say people are
better off not knowing about the world
so also I mean I think there's a lot of
steps that we can take in the internet
community to try to help ensure the
accuracy of the information on the
Internet in community projects like
Wikipedia or the various wikia sites the
communities tend to have a very
conservative and an old-fashioned view
of what information quality looks like
which sometimes surprising to people
they sort of assume it's going to be
some crazy myspace of information or
something but realistically you know a
lot of the scholarly standards that you
would hope for our exactly what the
community settles on so things like you
know comparing what's written in an
article to what the sources say and
judging the sources by their quality you
know is it a book published by a Harvard
University Press or is it a tabloid
magazine or is it some random crazy
webpage you know people really do have a
pretty good idea of how to assess the
quality of information and communities
are coming together to really think
about these things and to start to try
to build better and better quality
information resources so yeah there's a
lot of what you do